another powerful man faces a legal
reckoning over alleged sexual abuse and
a new example of the influence of
documentaries off-screen R&B singer R
Kelly's arrests on Friday on 10 sexual
abuse charges came just weeks after the
series surviving our Kelly debuted on
lifetime
three of the alleged victims are minors
Kelly denies the charges dream Hampton
is an executive producer of surviving
our Kelly and CBS News contributor Jody
Kanter is one of the New York Times
journalist who's reporting on Harvey
Weinstein led to the me to movement
dream and Jodi good morning good to have
both of you here dream did you ever
expect our Kelly to face charges I
didn't I hoped for a kind of social
death I remember when I first talked to
the other producers about what an ideal
outcome would be and I was thinking
about blackfish that film that made
people turn away from an amusement park
and I thought that people kind of having
all of the facts later would mean that
they wouldn't be able to so vociferously
kind of support him and talk about his
innocence and or have their heads in the
sand about who he was but no III
honestly didn't think would be here and
so Jodi what do you think that tells us
about the power of documentaries to
really affect change in the midst of
this me to movement well if you look at
this particular documentary that dream
made to me the power is the completeness
of the work it's an in-depth
psychological profile the number of
victims interviewed is really stunning
there's a lot of context about the movie
industry and so I think whether it's in
a newspaper article or a documentary or
a podcast what matters is the strength
of the reporting the victims voices
whether in an era where where the
definition of truth is very challenged
whether this comes across as something
very authentic and believable and we
also see the Miche movement now
transcend from Hollywood to the music
industry as well Ryan Adams recently a
few weeks ago and now our Kelly do you
think this is just the tip of the
iceberg are we gonna see more stories
come out of the music industry as a
whole it hasn't stopped generally it's
been how many months since we broke the
Weinstein story
and I think that what's powering this
whole thing is new information more
people coming forward accountability
leads to more accountability because
women are more willing to come forward
when they believe that people are
listening and that something may happen
and and actually Weinstein and our Kelly
are in very parallel positions now right
because there are criminal charges
against both of them we're awaiting to
the legal outcome on both of those cases
and I think that these are going to be
the two criminal trials the people
really look to for months to come
and the the reckoning will continue in
the courtroom I think part of the thing
Jodi that you exposed with Weinstein too
is the enablers dream you as well in
this documentary talking about those who
were that was the bodyguards that
tracked down these young girls for them
what did you learn about the system that
essentially supports and enables this
behavior the ecosystem partly just
partly explains why he can't make bail I
mean he has gone broke holding women in
his studio like this lifestyle that he
has moving women from state to state
girls really from state to state where
their parents can't find them he's gone
broke doing this he can't post $100,000
bail having made more than two hundred
million dollars in his career I mean a
52 year-old R&B singer is often a sad
song like it financially this you know
there are plenty examples of artists
that go broke in their 50s but this is
very particular to him settling lawsuits
to him you know having to manage six and
seven girls at a time dream tell me what
you think has changed about those who
came forward who spoke for this
documentary but then who might speak
going forward because there were a lot
who who didn't want to appear on camera
because they were worried about what
would happen - right we had to interview
so many women who collaborated off
camera but didn't want to come before
the cameras they knew they'd be doxxed
disbelieved dragged on Twitter and and
that happened to all of the survivors
who came forwarding and came on camera
so we had a lot of women that we talked
to because he's been doing this for
almost 30 years
who would corroborate details from the
other women but wouldn't come on camera
themselves and then when Kim Fox
at XI and Illinois the MDA in Illinois
and then also a prosecutor and Atlanta
asked for more women to come forward
that happens the floodgates kind of open
and both of those prosecutors are
getting those calls Jody I think people
may not realize just how much time it
takes reporting and also giving
assurance to these women that their
stories will be told fairly in getting
that body of evidence what's changed
since you started reporting is are there
more people feeling somewhat comfortable
in talking are we reaching an inflection
point I think we're seeing the problem
in a way that we never have before and
you can't solve a problem that you can't
see one of the many things that these
two cases are Kelley and Weinstein have
in common is the use of secret
settlements and NDA's to silence women I
want to throw a moral question out there
that we have not solved as a society are
we okay with confidential settlements
for allegations of sexual abuse if your
sister experience something really bad
at work and then she was offered
$300,000 to never speak with anybody
again about it should she take the money
on the one hand it might be her only
form of recompense but on the other hand
she would have to swear to never tell
her own story to never talk about
something very important that happened
her and she might be enabling an abuser
by doing that and we have not had a
discussion about that in society and
decided how we feel about what's
unfortunate about that it's the burden
should not be on the woman when it comes
to these kinds of decisions well what we
see with settlements is that
individually they can often make sense
to a woman they can feel like a best
option collectively they've been a
problem yeah all right well to be
continued thank you so much for joining
us during Hampton and Jody camp thank
you